we love opening and reading all of your
mail and i can't wait to get to your
letters but first
let's celebrate our zip code of the day
it's 55427
minneapolis minnesota home of our
affiliate station
care 11 and home of the minneapolis
skyway the longest continuous skyway
system in the world spanning
69 downtown blocks
in 2012 minneapolis celebrated the first
internet cat video festival at the
walker arts center
with more than ten thousand attendees
minneapolis minnesota we would love to
hear from you
and please we want you to know from our
show that we acknowledge you're the
epicenter of
news and demand for change in our
country so
we would love to have any exchange with
you possible
now to our first letter
okey okey-dokey
okay dear drew after being an
art teacher for 35 years i found a
second career
as the activity director at dowling
gardens in spark hill new york
our mission is to provide a safe
affordable caring housing community for
seniors
and due to the current pandemic all of
our activities have to be outside
i wonder if jonah would like to donate
one of his crocheted coverlets to one of
our residents
as a bingo prize from beth in spark hill
new york
all right it turns out that our
producers spoke with jonah and he was so
happy to help
that he is donating ten of his beautiful
creations
look at this big beautiful basket that
jonah did oh this is so
gorgeous look at these oh beth
i hope this is uh what you were thinking
thank you jonah thank you so much
oh jonah you're just the best
okay
turns out don't cross your legs and then
roll on in
okay next letter alrighty
hi drew i'm a stationary note card
jewelry designer and it's wonderful to
see
the art of letter writing making a
comeback here's your very own
personalized stationery
if you love it i'd be thrilled if you
could give a shout out to our little
boutique
rhubarb studios in ohio like all small
businesses today we could use a little
boost
jody findlay ohio
is there stationary oh there is oh my
goodness
oh i love it
oh gosh oh this is gorgeous
thank you jody this is
amazing stationary with my name on it
thank you thank you jody
i have to tell you you sent this to the
right place because i
love being a supporter of small
businesses and i'll do better than a
shout out we're going to feature you
in our little yellow book as well as in
our small
business gift guide so thank you very
much for your most
personal gift of personalized stationery
jody from one
lover of letters to another okay our
last letter comes from lance in
jackson california and he had actually
written to us before
asking about like a metal detector
because he wanted to go
trace howard hughes and have some
adventures i don't know let's find out
what he's writing about now
okay dear drew i'm glad i wrote you but
i wished i asked for world peace or
something and i'm withdrawing my request
for a metal detector
i still plan on exploring howard
hughes's old haunts and
don't be surprised to see a package in
the mail
old school with halseys like i promised
i have four daughters and my favorite
non-profit is tracy's place of hope
where they provide a safe place for
girls in bad situations and nowhere else
to go
you do so many wonderful things for this
world
please donate that money to them instead
lance and jackson california oh
i think lance we just figured out that
you're the good person here
and you're the inspiring one so we're
gonna donate
a thousand dollars that we were gonna
send to you
um but i will double it so we'll send
two thousand dollars to that charity
with your name on it lance because this
is all about you
so anyone else out there if you see
anything
want anything advice help maybe you want
to share something
send me a joke a photo request heartfelt
funny stories whatever it is
please go to our address at the
drewberrymore show.com
dear drew i would love to get your
letters thank you so much
and on behalf of the show beth jody and
lance thank you so much
for your letters and here are my
postcards to you
all right truly yours drew
[Music]
you